cuerpos alineados a lo largo de un
camino oído escenas de civiles dando rcp
mientras Suena la música de Los Barrios
cercanos una noche de celebración de
Halloween en seúl se convirtió en una
noche de auténtico horror después de que
una gran multitud se metiera en una
calle estrecha y con pendiente
aplastando a la gente hasta la muerte
el incidente ocurrió cuando un gran
número de personas que participaban en
el festival de Halloween se cayó lo que
provocó la muerte de muchos de los
participantes algunos supervivientes
informaron de que la multitud se volvió
cada vez más revoltosa antes de la
aplastamiento y otros dijeron que
estuvieron atrapados durante una hora
antes de ser rescatados había mucha
gente siendo empujada Y yo quedé
Atrapado entre la multitud y no pude
salir al principio era Inevitable que
ocurriera un accidente se estima que
100.000 personas habían acudido al
barrio de itae Wonder de seúl para las
celebraciones de Halloween por primera
vez desde 2019 con las tres tradiciones
de covid sobre las reuniones finalmente
levantadas tras la aglomeración las
autoridades enviaron un mensaje de texto
a todos los móviles del distrito de
youngsan diciendo la gente que se fuera
a casa debido a una situación de
emergencia cerca del hotel Hamilton el
presidente de Corea del Sur y un sukiol
emitió un comunicado en el que pedía que
se revisara la seguridad de los lugares
de celebración